welcome back defendant Daryl Brooks
continues to make waves in the courtroom
as he represents himself in the Waukesha
parade crash trial six people were
killed and dozens more injured when
prosecutors Say Brooks rammed his SUV
into the annual holiday parade last
November officials say Brooks continued
to drive even after he hit multiple
people and others banged on the hood of
the vehicle for him to stop he now faces
76 charges in connection to the crash
before the trial began Brooks elected to
represent himself declaring he's a
sovereign citizen after a 50-minute
uninterrupted ran by Brooks on Thursday
judge Jerome put her foot down on Friday
saying his arguments were irrelevant
Brooks continued to yell over the judge
at times in the presence of the jury
stop interrupting me the jury's coming
out we're continuing with this trial
despite your repeated efforts to disrupt
yesterday sit down yesterday alone sir
17 interruptions not including the
opportunity that I gave you where you
spent 50 minutes okay discussing what
were primarily either irrelevant or
baseless accusations and requests not
based in law or fact I was abundantly
patient with you yesterday
none of that is required sir because it
is you can't verify your belief that
that's the law doesn't make it so Mr
Brooks your belief that these are
legitimate legal positions doesn't
change the law and doesn't make it so so
again relevant because you didn't want
to I'm going to step off and give Mr
Brooks five minutes to cool off and when
that happens
Terry pays into the trial and we're
still seeing these baseless
interruptions and objections from Brooks
could he go too far and have that
privilege to represent himself taken
away absolutely there's a case for red
of the California it's a Supreme Court
case that interpreted the sixth
amendment saying look you have the right
to self-representation you have to be
competent and really it's not mental
competence here here we're talking about
educational background language
sufficiency you have to knowingly give
up your right to the attorney and you
have to understand the court proceedings
but that right like every other right is
not unlimited you must be able to show
that you are respectful that you're not
disruptive and once you're just you know
disruptive you can be asked to leave and
we've seen judge here do exactly that
and frankly I believe she could even at
this point take the right back from him
and make him have counsel so that she
can proceed to conclude this trial I
don't think she's going to do that she's
going to try to make it work with him
and maybe a occasionally have him step
out yeah absolutely judge Darrow there
could do exactly that now Dina the real
reason for the trial is that six people
were killed and many were injured but it
seems like Brooks's interruptions are
overshadowing the court proceedings how
will that affect the jury's deliberation
I think that's a great question because
it's so absolutely true he is making
himself kind of this centerpiece and a
really bad entertaining way and the fact
is us as viewers can maybe say oh my
gosh like cringe or whatever what he
says but those jurors are you know they
are giving up their time to sit there
and they do not find this humorous at
all and when he objects in ways when
victims family is on the stand you know
that has to put off the jurors in a way
that most lawyers would never let their
client do he's definitely making himself
look really badly in front of that jury
yeah I anticipate a very quick verdict
in this case and it might not be one
that Daryl Brooks or whatever he wants
to call himself is going to like now an
update on a story we first brought you
here on lawn crime daily autopsy results
reveal the cause of death for a 16 year
old Kylie Rodney Rodney was reported
missing in early August when she was
last seen at a party near Lake Tahoe she
texted her mother that she would soon
return home but never arrived her 2013
Honda CRV was also missing Weeks Later
the Oregon base dive team adventures
with purpose announced it found Rodney's
body in the overturned SUV California
officials later confirmed the remains
and vehicle belonged to Rodney this week
California officials announced Romney's
cause of death was drowning saying there
is no evidence of Foul Play Rodney's
death has now been ruled accidentally
coming up on Long crime daily the sorted
case of the so-called doomsday cult duel
will the pair be headed to trial in
January
plus it's Ohio versus George Wagner IV
jurors get an inside look at Wagner
family Dynamics